jason sadeskis yeah that last name is
tricky
ted lasso picked up a total of 20
nominations becoming the most
nominated freshman comedy series in tv
history
other big emmy news if i wasn't under
the restraints that i'm under right now
i feel so liberated framing britney
spears which brought the free brittany
movement back into the headlines earned
two emmy nominations including
outstanding documentary or non-fiction
special
i have mixed feelings actually because
britney is
right in the middle of this court battle
so it's an odd feeling
we spoke to director samantha stark
about the timing of it all
last month britney appeared in court and
alleged the conservatorship and her
father jamie were abusive making clear
she wants out what was your reaction as
you listen to britney's testimony
to me the idea that brittany said i'm
being abused i'm being trafficked and
there wasn't an immediate
kill switch shows like a huge fault in
the system to me
tomorrow will be another major court
hearing in brittany's battle for freedom
other headline making programs getting
nominations the first season
i had a major crush on jen hi this makes
my heart happy seeing you all together
the first question like how do you feel
i was like
and then started crying hbo max's
friends the reunion was nominated for
outstanding variety special
concerns and conversations about how
dark his skin might be when he's born
what oprah was nominated for outstanding
hosted nonfiction series or special for
the bombshell cbs primetime special
which sent
shock waves around the world and
fractured the royal family
do you all watch the ground reward some
of that
watch some of it well the crown which
centered around the marriage downfall of
harry's parents prince charles and the
late princess diana
tied the mandalorian for most emmy
nominations this year
each receiving 24. and the duke of
hastings may have left bridgerton but
voters gave reggae jean page a surprise
parting gift
his first emmy nomination for
outstanding lead actor in a drama series
i'm sure you gotta be surprised and
check out the reaction of this
first-time nominee
the flight attendants kaylee cuoco and
hack star gene smart a double nominee
with her supporting role in mayor of
east town
are the ones to beat in the lead actors
comedy category
what a year nbc's this is us was the
only scripted network show to score
six nominations including acting nods
for sterling k
brown and chris sullivan the texts have
been flying sterling and i
have exchanged congratulations uh the
whole cast is
is excited to be to be nominated for
best drama
we're coming for you netflix you better
look out
one major snub no nomination for nicole
kidman in the undoing
the emmys will air live sunday september
19th
on cbs winners will take the stage in
front of an in-person audience with
first-time host
cedric the entertainer yeah baby i'm
about to be
hosting the eps